hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the general
framework that John Rawls is elaborating
in his book a theory of justice can be
extended beyond just the narrow confines
of discussions about distributive
justice and brought into the field of
moral theory or thinking about ethics
more broadly and he talks about this a
good bit rouille on in the work and
other people have taken his ideas and
extended them to ethical decision-making
or deliberation or moral judgment more
broadly so we should think about what
the implications of his work is and what
he in fact has to say about it and so
the place to begin is actually in
Chapter three this is very early on in
the work and he's talking about why he
calls what he's doing a social contract
or contract here in view when there
actually isn't any moment of contracting
it's kind of an abstract hypothesis that
that's going on and so he says that
there may be an objection to the term
contract and related expressions but I
think that it works reasonably well to
understand it one has to keep in mind
a certain level of abstraction in
particular the content of the relevant
agreement is not to enter a given
society or to adopt a given form of
government but and here's where we see
that there's some very clear ethical
implications to it to accept certain
moral principles so the entire
discussion whether we frame it in terms
of contract or contract Arianism or
whatever terminology that we're using
it's not about creating an entirely new
society it's about evaluating currently
existing society's policies
organizations groups and thinking about
them from the basis of several moral
principles that he thinks we ought to be
accepting so he says the undertakings
referred to are purely hypothetical a
contract view holds that certain
principles would be accepted in a
well-defined initial situation so he is
providing the well-defined initial
situation actually in the very first few
chapters of this work and then he's
refining it through the rest of it and
what is that it's an initial condition
of all of us making judgments about what
society ought to look like under a veil
of ignorance and then in his view coming
up with these two basic overarching
principles of justice that governed the
way in which we create the rest of the
society so like I said it's about
accepting certain moral principles and
he says that there's a good reason to
pick this this term of contract it's
evocative or connotative of certain
things he says the merit of this
terminology is that it conveys the idea
that principles of justice may be
conceived of as principles that would be
chosen by a rational person so that's
one proviso and that in this way
conceptions of justice may be explained
and justified right so he says the other
thing that that is really good about
this
we should find attractive is that it
deals with the fact of us being within a
society that where we don't have
complete agreements already he says
principles of justice deal with
conflicting claims upon the advantages
won by social cooperation so by virtue
of existing within a society or a matrix
going beyond say just the family we are
involved in social cooperation we have
roads for example because somebody
actually built them and that required
paying the people who are building the
roads to to put them through there and
the surveyors to actually decide where
the road ought to go and how far it can
go this way in that land and there's
upkeep and all of that requires you know
a lot of social coordination and there's
plenty of room in there for competing
interests so he says that these
principles apply to the relations among
several persons or groups and the word
contract is an apt one why because it
suggests this plurality as well as the
condition that the appropriate division
of advantages must be in accordance with
principles acceptable to all party so he
says this is why we want to use the word
contract the idea is that when you have
a contract there's some mutually
agreed-upon arrangement that everybody
may not be perfectly happy with they'd
all like to get a bit more out of it but
they can they can say that they've been
consulted they've been brought into it
so that's important well that's why
we're gonna use the term contract now
justice is fairness or this contract
aryan theory that he's putting forth he
says is in some ways just the tip of the
iceberg and he says that it's not a
complete contract theory this is also in
Chapter three why he says it's clear
that this contract harry an idea can be
extended to the choice of more or less
notice the term that he chooses here an
entire ethical system
so what does he mean by that he
clarifies this in very conscience he
says a system including principles not
only for justice but for all the virtues
that is for all of the dispositions to
behave and be motivated in certain ways
and it would also thereby include the
vices things that you shouldn't do and
this is indeed what Kant himself does in
the metaphysical the metaphysics of
morals which includes the metaphysical
elements of justice on the one hand and
the meta meta physical elements of
virtue on the other hand so Rawls is
actually following a well-established
path in making this distinction and you
could say if you want to be very speak
very broadly well we've got you know
society and how we ought to arrange
things there and we're not so worried
about motivations in that case and then
we have the whole realm of personal life
and relationships and our own actions
and motivations and so contract arianism
of the sort that Rawls is elaborating
would in fact extend to that where we
want going to want to develop it that
that way so he goes through a couple
things talking about how we would extend
this and I think we can think of three
different things there's as we just
mentioned extension to virtues extension
to our own particular motivations or
those of other people we could think
about an account anyway the Maxim's by
which we regulate our actions we could
think about it in other ways as well but
he before we get to that he says that
even rightness as fairness hasn't been
adequately conceptualized just in
talking about justice he says that I'm
going to consider only principles of
justice and others closely related to
them I'm going to make no attempt to
discuss the virtues in a systematic way
a next step he says would be to study
the more general view suggested by the
name rightness as fairness and you know
we might even think you notice one word
that he's not using there
even thank goodness here is part of the
virtue thing that he has another really
interesting suggestion he talks about
extending this even further to embrace
other things he says this wider theory
fails to embrace all moral relationships
why because it would seem to include
only our relations with other persons
what would it leave out of account as he
says animals and the rest of nature
animals are not persons for Rawls but we
could still think about our comportment
towards them so we could ask ourselves
you know whether factory farming would
be commune o compatible with the moral
system that he's laying out here drawing
upon this notion of contract Arianism
and probably the answer would be no but
we would have to carry out a sort of
reasoning process about that and there
could be two sides that it could be that
it's bad for the people who are involved
and they can't reasonably agree to it
given all the different things that go
along with with factory farming but we
could also talk about it being bad for
the animals themselves even though
they're not considered persons or for
nature the environment in a broader
sense so this is at least in its core it
has the potential to be a much broader
moral theory a little bit later in the
next chapter he talks about the reason
why he's still talking about contract
and he says that it's a hypothetical and
so he says it's natural to ask why if
this agreement is never actually entered
into we should take any interest in
these principles moral or otherwise and
that's that's a good question isn't he
just doing sort of a abstract parlor
game here playing around with ideas
engaging in a certain kind of utopianism
Rawls thinks that the answer to that is
no by outlining these principles that
will never be fully realized
we are providing ourselves with the
skeleton of a moral theory which he
takes to be in some respect
a exposition of our moral sentiments but
here in chapter 4 he says the answer to
this question why should we take any
interest in this is that the conditions
embodied in the description of the
original position are ones we do in fact
accept so again this is a fairly
standard move in outlining a new moral
theory you say listen I'm just kind of
clarifying what it is that that decent
human beings already do believe I'm
trying to provide some some articulation
here of something that you see that you
know the utilitarian is doing this even
Aristotle does this to some extent right
so Rawls is doing a well-established
move here in saying that these are these
are principles we should accept if we
really think it through if we're
thinking about it in a objective
unbiased way and not worrying about
whether it's gonna raise our taxes or
you know let our neighbor you know have
better stuff than us if we're if we're
really thinking it through as a rational
beings then we will accept these
principles but he's got another thing
that he says after this or if we do not
then perhaps no notice that we're
perhaps we can be persuaded to do so by
philosophical reflection why because
each aspect of the contractual situation
can be given supporting grounds so if
you don't already accept this it's it
provides a sort of way of a leverage a
rhetoric for reaching people who don't
buy into justice as fairness so you
could for example use this to try to
convince people who are racists for
sentimental reasons that perhaps racism
is not the way that they ought to go and
shouldn't be regulating their moral
decision-making right so the original
position and and the principles that he
derives provide guidance for moral
theory and he does have a discussion
about moral theory
in Chapter nine which is some remarks
about moral theory a lot of this is
concerned with what he calls reflective
equlibrium so I'm going to keep this
this discussion here focused on the
parts that are not really looking at
that early on in that he says that when
we're engaging in moral theorization he
says let us assume each person beyond a
certain age and possessed of the
requisite intellectual capacity develops
a sense of justice under normal keyword
there normal source of social
circumstances we acquire a skill in
judging things to be just and unjust and
supporting these judgments by reason we
ordinarily have some desire to act in
accord with these pronouncements and
expect a similar desire on the part of
others and says this is very complex
we're not going to try to get into the
complexity but he says we may think of a
moral theory at first and he says this
is a provisional view as the attempt to
describe our moral capacity or in this
present sense my theory the theory of
justice is describing our sense of
justice and he says what we require here
is a formulation of a set of principles
that when they're conjoined to other
stuff our beliefs and knowledge of
circumstances would lead us to make
these judgments with their supporting
reason yeah here's another key we were
to apply these principles
conscientiously and intelligently so
Rawls is not saying that his theory of
justice describes how people do in fact
behave much of the time people are not
behaving that way there are many
problems with this he is saying that if
we are being conscientious diligent
rational that this is the moral theory
that we would accept so that it's not
just a theory of justice but actually
more broadly speaking it could provide
an entire ethics for us to regulate our
moral decision-making and evaluation and
development
you